let's talk about the 16 biggest keto
mistakes that will block your progress
all right number one not reading labels
you end up eating a so-called keto
friendly something and it's not actually
keto friendly now as you start doing
this you're going to get better and
better and you're going to catch things
and you're going to learn certain things
but let's just start with the atkins
bars and shakes okay if you look at the
ingredients you'll find all sorts of
things that are not just not keto
friendly but they're not healthy at all
they have this protein blend with soy
protein isolates which is really hard in
the liver and it will increase your
estrogen and its gmo so there could be
traces of glyphosate which is an
herbicide then they put whey protein in
there which is the highest on the
insulin index and then sodium caseinate
which is not the best normal source of
protein but the combination of those is
very very inexpensive protein all right
and then we have this thing called
polydextrose
what the heck is polydextrose it's a
synthetic fiber right and they'll say
that oh it's a fiber so it's not going
to increase insulin and even the fda
approved it as being a dietary fiber but
the research is so new and i know people
who consume products like this
results are not near where they should
be and they have bloating and they have
digestive issues and so any of these new
synthetic fibers
i just would recommend staying away from
them and then we have an ingredients
maltitol which is the
worst sugar alcohol i mean it's
recommended for diabetics but on the
glycemic index it's like a 52 and that's
just like way too high it's the absolute
worst
so-called diabetic friendly sugar that
you can consume and i've done a video
just on that one
sugar alcohol and then they add
vegetable oil right but what type of
vegetable are they using
soy oil
gmo very cheap and very high in omega-6
which creates inflammation there's
artificial flavoring
and they also add maltodextrin
now on the glycemic index maltodextrin
is one of the sugars that is even higher
than glucose is the worst sugar that you
can consume i don't know why they put it
in their low carb keto friendly
bars and of course then you have
slimfast right i mean they play both
sides they sell to people who like sugar
and now they're getting into the keto
market so the first ingredient is milk
protein concentrate and of course
it's not organic or grass-fed cows
guarantee they use canola oil which is
gmo
they also use maltodextrin artificial
flavors i mean i think they used to have
a different formula but they've been
bought out they use whey protein isolate
which is very high on the insulin index
and they use this other fiber called iso
multi-oligosaccharides
imo and i used to recommend it for
various syrups and different ingredients
because it gives you that wonderful
texture but
it's going to spike your blood sugars so
you do not want to consume anything with
imo and then you have other brands like
hilo chips they have potato starch
that's not keto friendly
so if you see potato starch tapioca
starch tapioca fiber
and soluble corn fiber
i would recommend not consuming it i
mean even the soluble corn fiber there's
10 different versions
some have forty percent sugar some have
four percent sugar so you don't really
know what you're getting but even v8 now
is putting the soluble corn fiber in
their v8 so they can say it now comes
with fiber the fiber's not from
vegetable it's from this soluble corn
fiber now i just need to say this really
quick the study that they did with
soluble corn fiber and they said it will
lower your blood sugars well they're
comparing it to
glucose so that's the control so if
you're comparing it to glucose and it
lowers your blood sugars more than
glucose then they can say it lowers your
blood sugar but they sometimes fail to
mention that they're comparing it to
glucose so number one very important
read the ingredients always especially
in the beginning so you get used to it
all right number two not looking at the
serving sizes there's a couple points
about this number one
maybe you look at the carbs in salad
dressing and it says two grams of sugar
right and that is per serving size not
per
bottle
so it's like per teaspoon so who would
use one teaspoon of salad dressing on
their salad i might use six or seven or
even eight so you have to multiply the
serving size by the sugars or the carbs
to get the actual value the other little
trick that they use
is it's called a roundup trick let's say
a carb has point eight carbs it's less
than one so they rounded to zero so if
you increase the serving size
you could be getting a lot of carbs but
not knowing it because of this rounding
little trick that they use all right
number three judging your success based
on weight loss
let's say you started the ketogenic plan
and you didn't lose weight in the first
week and you go wow it didn't work i'm
gonna quit
what you have to realize is that the
first fat that's going to be burned is
the fat inside your liver okay a really
interesting study that shows that you
can reduce 50 percent of your liver fat
within the first 14 days
so your body is going to get rid of that
before your belly fat so you may not see
much weight loss initially especially
since you have to get healthy to lose
weight the concept of get healthy lose
weight is very very very important you
don't lose weight and get healthy you
have to get healthy
then lose the weight
and you might want to let that sink in
because it's a heavy
concept it is something that is very
opposite of what people have been
telling you your whole life they've been
telling you to just lose weight so you
can get healthy because obesity is a
health risk well actually it works a lot
better if you just focus on your health
because
the weight will come off as a natural
consequence of being healthy and
sometimes getting healthy takes a little
bit longer especially if you've been
eating poorly your whole life all right
number four comparing your results with
others like your spouse not a good idea
it's very discouraging especially if
you're a woman and you're comparing your
weight loss to men because
men don't have as much estrogen and so
women have estrogen and estrogen makes
fat especially around the hips the
buttocks the thighs so you can't really
do a good
comparison all right number five not
consuming enough salt when you're on a
ketogenic plan um you're gonna lose more
salt and if you don't add more salt i'm
gonna recommend sea salt
not table salt you're going to feel
weaker you're going to feel the keto flu
so add more salt to prevent
those two big symptoms all right number
six
the cheat day
i don't know whoever came up with the
cheat day
but um i'm not going to recommend a
on this plan i mean would you recommend
a cheat day when you're married
let me find out hey honey karen i had a
quick question yeah
what do you think about this uh concept
of a cheat day for a marriage
[Music]
all right there's your answer cheap days
don't work in the marriage and they
don't work in your diet all right number
seven you're doing too much or too
little fat
now even though the ketogenic diet
is about 75
fat i found a couple interesting things
about this that may help you initially
when you do the ketogenic plan if you
increase more fat so you can fast longer
that's going to help you we're not
trying to lose weight necessarily we're
just trying to fast longer and that
transition might only take like
two or three days when you start to get
into ketosis and your appetite goes away
and you're fasting longer
and you're continuing to
add all these additional fats like mct
oil the keto snacks the keto bombs are
called
all the extra butter on top of the fat
that comes with your
protein
you may find that your weight loss is
not as much as it should because
if given the choice the body will always
burn the dietary fat before your own fat
so what you might want to do is not go
low-fat but just not try to add all this
fat to the meal
and just eat the fat that normally comes
with the protein
and it will help you lose weight a bit
faster but if your metabolism is fast
just keep getting more fat because it's
working realize this that
if something is working don't change it
okay if something is not working
change it all right number eight
you're eating too much protein too much
protein can increase insulin and that
can slow you down now protein is the big
variable
depending on your
size
your metabolism
your age if you're male you're female if
you're working out
but i wouldn't start doing high protein
i would definitely keep it moderate and
moderate
is kind of a broader definition it could
be between three to six to seven to
eight ounces per meal of protein so
plant by ear and i guess a real good
rule of thumb would be
if you're female consume the protein the
size of the palm of your hand if you're
a male
consume double the protein the size of
your palm okay that's just a very
general
guideline and number nine this is very
very important
you need to do intermittent fasting with
keto together okay
you're not going to be able to achieve
your weight loss goal without in a
minute fasting you're not going to
achieve your health goals most likely if
you're not doing intermittent fasting
unless
you're extremely healthy going into this
which i haven't really seen that many
healthy people
especially recently number ten
i wouldn't put much credence into the
urinary ketone strips okay they're
called urine ketone strips
why well they're good initially but
realize as your body starts to burn more
ketones
guess what you're going to waste less
ketones so you're not going to see them
in the urine so guess what you check
your urine and you don't see any ketones
you think oh it's not working when it is
working
the blood ketones are a much better way
to test your ketones but you really
don't need either one the way that you
know that ketogenic diet is working is
if your hunger goes away if your
cravings go away and then you start
seeing some of the other benefits with
energy cognitive
weight loss
mood elevation those are the true
indicators that it's working all right
number 11
giving up when actually it's working
you start the plan
and then you find that you're you're
expecting certain results they don't
happen and you say that didn't work when
in fact it was working
well let me just give you an example um
there are a lot of people who lose the
initial water weight and then they
plateau
and then they might not lose weight for
a while or they might lose one pound a
week
and they don't realize that the most a
person could lose if they're healthy is
two pounds
the average amount that a person will
lose is one pound that's normal and so
they're expecting something like five
pounds when that's not realistic and so
one pound weight loss per week is
actually not not too bad it's pretty
good but and some people they may have
to get healthy first and their stomach
starts shrinking their clothes are
looser why because they are growing more
muscle tissue
and if we compare the weight per volume
the same volume of muscle to fat
muscle is heavier than fat so they might
not lose weight because they're growing
muscle they're healing because of all
the growth hormone but they are
shrinking because the fat cells are
getting smaller all right number 12 12.
now i think i already mentioned this but
you're changing something when it's
working you never want to change
anything if it's working just ride the
wave when you evaluate someone you're
basically comparing what they did before
to what they did now and you're looking
for any changes that occur and that can
give you important information to know
if you should
change something
revert back to something or strengthen
something
if you found by adding intermittent
fasting to your keto plan
doubled your results then you would keep
that going if you found that your
results stopped as soon as you started
adding these atkins bars then you need
to
omit those things all right you got that
okay 13.
eating when you're not hungry okay you
don't want to do that because
you're burning fat your body is eating
its own fat and so many people are in
this habit of eating that they just
routinely eat
i mean everyone else is eating why
shouldn't they eat
so really pay attention to
if you're truly hungry now
there's a couple little points of this
in the morning especially eight o'clock
in the morning you have this spike of
cortisol and you may find that your
hunger goes up because of this other
hormone
but you shouldn't eat because your
energy didn't drop you feel okay you
just might feel this wave of hunger or
your stomach starts growling
that should go away so we want to
differentiate between
true hunger where you need to eat
and
maybe just your body going through these
hormonal cycles where it triggers hunger
and the way to differentiate that is if
you have a hunger and you ignore it and
it goes away then you know it's not
really time to eat but let's say you try
to ignore it and it persists okay that
means you need to eat or let's say that
you feel weak when you're hungry that
means you need to eat and so that's just
a really important point all right
number 14. and this is another important
one your estimation of effort or your
estimation of time you have to realize
that if you take someone who starts keto
and let's say they're 35 or 40 years old
they've eaten
poorly for 30 to 40 years okay now
they're going to start this keto plan
and their mind they're thinking i'm
going to just turn everything around in
one to two weeks
they have severe insulin resistance okay
i mean like really bad i just want to
let you know from just a lot of
experience in this area usually the
estimation of effort is a lot more than
what the person thinks the estimation of
the time it takes
to reverse insulin resistance is usually
a lot longer
than you think and so if you go into
this
having this unrealistic expectation
where this this thought that wow it's
going to happen really quick and it
doesn't you're going to be very
frustrated it's much better if you have
your estimation a lot longer so that way
you set yourself up for success because
you're going to stick with it a lot
longer i mean some people that have
diabetes that are doing this uh it takes
a year or two years to reverse this
insulin resistance it's just the truth
of what it takes i mean so what it's
going to take time the bottom line is
there is a way to eventually improve
this but the cool thing is you're you're
going to see progressive improvements
and you can always improve things okay
you can always speed things up all right
number 15.
i kind of already covered that um but
there's a difference between hunger and
your time for eating and i think the
best indicator is if you're
feeling fatigued or you're feeling you
know dizzy or
light-headed
or weak
you need to eat number 16
another really important one
that people really don't understand
is all it takes is a very
tiny bit of carbohydrate
to block your weight loss for a longer
period of time in fact this was in
guidance physiology and i've done videos
on this
it takes a small spike of insulin which
is triggered by carbohydrate
to block your fat burning
so let's say for example you consumed a
piece of bread or a half a glass of wine
just realize that that can block fat
burning for
24 48 hours so i'm just telling you this
because
if you're doing this program
and you're not a hundred percent you're
sort of doing it and let's say every
other day
you're doing carbs and you're not seeing
results then you know why
now especially if you
went hog wild drinking all this alcohol
let's say on friday night
chances are you're not going to be back
in to ketosis until monday or even
tuesday all right so now that you have
that there's another really good video
that i want you to watch on the
acceptable liquids on keto
check it out here
you